okay welcome back to everybody who is uh
back to joining us again and also
welcome to everybody who's new I'd like
to acknowledge our sponsors thank you to
TD Ameritrade for sponsoring the venue
the space that we have here today also
thanks to num focus for supporting this
Meetup as well as Midas at the
University of Michigan for providing the
food a couple important points emergency
exits there's one right over here am i
right and also through the doors that
you came through also to the right
please do not take the elevators as
always we're soliciting feedback so if
there's any things that as patty to Ann
Arbor can do better please let us know
also all of our videos or most of our
videos are recorded and posted on
YouTube and so if you go to a tiny dot
CC a tube high data videos there should
be our playlists they'll be available to
you and also to respect the speaker
unless you have quick questions try to
please hold them until the end there
will be time at the end to ask questions
and always remember that where to borrow
space so do clean up after yourselves in
terms of the food the garbage is over by
where the food is like the reminders of
the pie-dar code of conduct and the
short version is dedicated to providing
a harassment free meeting experience for
everyone regardless of gender sexual
orientation gender identity and
expression disability physical
appearance body size race or religion we
do not tolerate harassment of reading
participants in any form all
communication should be appropriate for
a professional audience including people
of many different backgrounds sexual
language and imagery is not appropriate
for any of our meet of events be kind to
others do not insult a predominant
attendees behave professionally remember
that harassment and sexist racist or
exclusionary jokes are not appropriate
for khadija attendees violating these
rules may be asked to leave the meetup
but otherwise thank you for making the
same welcoming environment for everybody
and of course we always like to do a an
icebreaker so this way when you leave
you'll hopefully have met somebody with
similar interests so the suggestion that
we had today was either terms
somebody in front of you to the left to
the right introduce yourselves and tell
them your favorite colored sock mm-hmm
go ahead what color do you prefer for a
sock
[Music]
what do I hear hi what what color do you
like the most black bull I go with
orange myself that is bold
all right thank you
so hopefully you will have met somebody
at this you know just a quick plug for
our this month in data science news
story so a Facebook recently announced
that they have a new algorithm that does
unsupervised machine translation so
traditionally to do machine language
translation between different languages
you need to have a one-to-one mapping
but there's some new work that's coming
out of Facebook that shows otherwise
that seems to be very promising and
interesting so definitely go check that
out and I'd like to also I mentioned
next months you know this will be done
in collaboration with the our user group
in Ann Arbor as well so we have julia
silky who works at stack overflows one
of the data scientists there and she'll
be coming here to talk to us about one
of the books that she published in a
rally called thats related text mining
using tidy data principles so definitely
sign up for this and I welcome anybody
in the community right now that might
have a community announcement whether
you're hiring looking looking for a job
are there any anybody let's start with
been in the back
[Laughter]
another is like a datawarehouse
generalist in those ETL and business
intelligence for a roll up in Brighton
and if anybody goes a high trust
security person who would like to be a
high trust Geordi manager in Seattle
yeah look for Ben in the picture I think
high thumb had
yes
[Music]
nice work
any other announcements all right great
so with that I'm very excited to
introduce our speaker today I've been
trying to get her back out here for a
while now but so ever Mike used to work
for you data science company called data
scope analytics based out of Chicago and
they were recently maybe a year ago a
year ago they weren't quite by I do and
so Rebecca is working there now as their
design director and he's gonna be
telling us about the intersection of
deep learning and Matt Damon and
something about the the coolest looking
guy yes he'll look at him so let's
welcome thank you thanks John hi
everyone thank you very much for having
me here I'm really excited to talk here
and I'm gonna talk about how deep
learning reveals the essence of Matt
Damon that's the name of my talk but
really the actual title of the talk is
that I decided that my face looked kind
of like a movie stars and I wanted to
prove that using deep learning so today
we're gonna go on a journey to prove how
handsome I am using deep learning okay
first of all who do I think I am Sean
thank you very much for that
introduction I the reason I wanted to
mention one thing just a little bit is
that I'm a design director at ideal
focusing on our offering that we call
augmented intelligence we call it
augmented intelligence you know you can
think of it as like a play on words like
artificial intelligence AI augmenting
people's intelligence instead of
replacing humans in a machine let's
enhance their skills and capabilities
that's what we try to do and actually
that's not that different from what was
happening in the like first heyday of
Silicon Valley and Steve Jobs said the
computer is the most remarkable tool
we've ever come up with it's the bicycle
for our minds what he was talking about
was basically augmenting like computers
augments
people's intelligence right and actually
Steve Jobs and you know Microsoft Apple
Bill Gates they all kind of took
inspiration from Xerox PARC which is in
the 50s 60s they were really developing
how to augment human intelligence this
is like way before deep learning became
what it is today but this whole
augmentation augmenting intelligence
thing is not a complete and new thing it
was there at the beginning of
cybernetics as you know as a discipline
and what you see here is from a paper
written by Doc M d'hubert and he if you
haven't seen this you should go google
this he has given the mother of all
demos basically a computer demo in the
60s that does everything that we do
today it's really mind-boggling you
should see it but what they were
focusing on at Xerox PARC
to augment people's intelligence was to
understand what can we do to take off
tasks that are not really suited well to
human mind so here you can see a
typewriter a pencil a pencil tape to a
brick right and this is a person like
typing the same sentence or writing the
same sentence with the same tools this
takes seven seconds this takes 20
seconds and this takes 65 seconds right
what we are trying to do what I mean by
augmenting in the old building people is
to take something we do like this remove
the brick and get there or even better
get here right and this is decidedly
different from trying to make a writing
machine that just like writes
automatically instead of you that like
you don't have to do anything what it's
doing is it's combining your best thing
and some machine doing what it does best
to sort of like elevate both so for
example you're drawing a circle right
well you can just like try to draw it
like this this isn't a great great sort
of task for our hand we kind of like
don't - yeah we're all right here's one
tool that kind of like makes it much
much easier right
and here is usually how you would draw a
circle today right like there are layers
in Photoshop and you can move things but
my point in all of this because I'm
about to talk about generating images
and like why they could be really really
cool and useful when you get to this
stage right you don't have to worry at
all you don't have to spend any buffer
in your mind about being careful with
your lines and like making sure that you
got it just right if you're at this
stage you can just like draw 20 circles
real quick and make something more
interesting with it in in a short amount
of time
so think about what we've been doing
with technology this kind of stuff has
been happening like I said for a long
time especially let's focus on personal
computer technologies right we keep
augmenting the next thing so that like
the plus between humans and machines
sort of like elevates both of them okay
this is one of my favorite technologies
control-z undo and I think it's
groundbreaking because it takes away the
fear of doing something wrong with a
computer but it's also it didn't come
from
hey this like completely new technology
is of like I'm doing things we
discovered it accidentally or as the
next natural sort of like stage in
personal computer technologies no it was
about people's needs understanding sort
of like what kind of boost does your
brain need and then giving it to them it
was it's basically memory you just saved
the states that are previously in memory
it's actually easy technology wise but
figuring out the right augmentation is
kind of the challenge ok let's move from
this augmentation idea of like it's like
trying to get something done like
writing something but let's also move
towards creative process so I showed you
the circles well if you can draw a
circle perfectly real quick then you can
do a lot with them but Ken machines and
this like neo deep learning technologies
actually can help inspire us even
further than that
Robin Sloane is an author ok and he did
this
he basically built a model let it read
50 or like I know I don't remember how
many but like a lot of old science
fiction books right and the model just
like generates new sentences or just
generates more science fiction texts
it's just trying to come up with things
that it has seen in old books right but
here's the cool part
he made this into a plugin so that in
the editor he starts typing a sentence
okay and then he hits a key binding and
the computer just like completes it for
him okay it again and if he doesn't like
it he can just I keep doing this and
basically what he's doing is he's
getting inspiration from this model
right this is the system of the man in
the machine and basically plagiarism
becomes a bit of an issue here like okay
if they have read like if the model has
read all these books it's not stealing a
sentence but is it stealing something
what's going on there that's interesting
but what I want to focus on is as these
new technologies around us all this
machine learning is developing this is
actually creating a lot of really really
interesting opportunities for us to
offload parts of the creative process
onto a machine and actually really find
our own voice actually in collaboration
with a machine that's really interesting
here's what he did next after this
it was raining cats and dogs is just the
sentence give me another sentence she
left me forever what it does is it's
trying to in the meaning space fill in
the gradual sentences that go from this
to this already it's not good so when
you look at it it doesn't feel like a
very smooth transition right I wouldn't
call this like very useful but it's
interesting right what what we are doing
is sort of collaborating with machines
in creative endeavors which is really
interesting okay
and here is like what I want to mainly
focus on in terms of this creative focus
around neural networks and deep learning
so I'm gonna talk about generative
adversarial networks basically all these
faces that you're seeing and we're going
to get back to them they were imagined
by a computer we just showed a computer
a whole bunch of faces this is what a
face looks like and then ask the
computer to generate like more new faces
and these are faces some of them
nightmarish some of them are very
passable as human beings so we'll get to
it first of all okay how do you get a
computer to look at a bunch of faces and
understand what a face is right let's
talk about how it works okay so this is
actually not a single neural network
doing something it's a framework with
like two separate warnet networks
working with each other okay let's call
one of them a forger and the other one a
cop okay
so there's what this is what the forger
does okay all it does is it takes some
numbers it takes a vector right don't
worry about what the vector might be is
just like five numbers right and spits
out an image if you give it the same
four numbers it spits out the exact same
image to give it different numbers it
spits out a completely different image
right but it's an image it's an image
maker generator thing so it could also
generate I mean it's basically pixels it
could also generate an image that looks
like a face right or it could generate
something that looks kinda maybe like a
face like all of these are potentials
but what it does is take numbers give me
much what the cop does is take an image
and tell me if it's an actual face or
not right so it will look at this think
about it and I don't think that's a face
it would say it would be correct this is
a fake this is not a face then looks at
this and it says like yeah this looks
very much like a face and again correct
real and you look at it and say is this
real or not
now in this case I'm also going to say
fake what I mean by real or fake is that
this is an actual image of a person's
face versus like some generated image
that didn't come from an actual real
photography like process okay
now this basically forges faces this
determines if they're forgeries or not
right that's the whole idea we start
with like just these dumb things we
didn't train them yet and obviously we
have our millions of images of faces to
show the computer right okay here's how
it all goes it's an arms race that
starts with the forger sending an image
to the cop now the forger can either
Forge one itself or it can pick one from
a real image and say hey this is a real
image now this has to figure out if it's
real did you really pick it from the
real ones or did you just like come up
with it yourself that's what the cop has
to do so the forger starts generates an
image not a real one since hey here try
this
this is totally a face I took this from
the from the real set and the cop very
proudly says no this is fake the cup is
correct it understands that it's correct
doesn't need to change anything I'm the
best cup in the world the forger is the
in real Depression right like I am not
worth anything I am not working this is
not happening so how is it trying to
figure it out so what it's doing is it's
trying to get better at fooling it right
like it sort of like makes them a bit
more passable and the cup now is fooled
let's say in this example and says hey
this is real now once it realizes once
the forger says no it wasn't real I
actually didn't send you a real image I
faked this from myself I'm really proud
once the cop learns the truth then okay
how can I improve myself right how did
it fool me how did I not understand that
this wasn't real so then it sort of
changes its parameters a little bit and
then back and forth okay
forgers happy
now the smarter cop denies it now the
forger needs to get smarter so basically
these two guys are getting better and
better at fooling the other one or
catching the other one right so you keep
doing this over and over again you keep
sending real images you keep making some
and basically as this keeps going the
forger is getting better and better at
fooling the cop and the cop is getting
better and better at not being fooled
we're it a clue Bri AIT's in something
like this so and the forger is really
called the generator because it's
generating images and the cop is called
the discriminator as its discriminating
if it's real or not but by the end of
this equilibria ting this is a pretty
good generator and this is a pretty good
like you know cop - but like this one
really was there - you know feel the
mastermind evil of this guy right this
is really what we want we use the cop to
get it better
okay so Ganz or generative adversarial
networks basically a couple of networks
one generator one discriminator which we
trained with an arms race but how do
their innards work what would we see if
we ripped open their guts well let's
start with the more straightforward one
- discriminator the cop that just has to
classify an image and say fake or real
okay now let's make the problem a little
bit simpler while they're working on
this this is an image of an optometrist
I have an irrational fear and hatred of
optometrists so they keep showing you
things like that that you can't see but
in this case this optometrist is just a
little bit extra evil okay
because he is trying to trick you let's
zoom in on this okay well you probably
still can't see it let me zoom in more
okay some of these are not letters
this is not a letter you're not blind
this is just the cruel joke okay this is
an O X I can kind of see the H this is
fake see nope that's a Y that's almost
like something but it's not okay so
basically imagine this is what we're
trying to do some of these are actual
real letters and some of those are not
letters by the way all we did is it's
the same problem we just went from a lot
of pixels to three by three grayscale
and letters instead of faces but it's
the exact same problem for the cop okay
now this is of course an age-old machine
learning sort of thing to do
classification we are going to take some
images and say real or fake okay we're
going to train this model and then it
can basically take an image and tell us
what it is so a very straightforward
really old-school you know like standard
way of doing classification one of the
first like machine learning things that
you learn if you study machine learning
is like logistic regression okay
basically we need to represent our image
with some features send it to a logistic
regression which will give us a
probability of this thing being a real
letter or a fake letter right so and
basically obviously the 50% probability
is the cutoff so if our model think 60%
this is an actually letter so we're
gonna go with like real letter okay so
that's how it goes it's pretty
straightforward
and how do we what kind of features that
we use though how do we represent these
images by numbers that's actually pretty
straightforward to write like these are
basically matrices of how dark a pixel
is right so and there are nine pixels so
you can think of those as like those
numbers represents this image okay you
give it to the logistic regression let's
say this is an H it does well on the
reality score 80% good 3% not real good
but the problem with this is it cannot
catch complex local and nonlinear
relationships it cannot understand all
the like how all of these things
intricately play with each other it it
is it cannot extract these structures of
lines crossing to make a tea and an age
like it actually focuses on like how
strong is this guy here or not so it can
learn maybe like but a lot of theta like
very very specific shapes but it is
difficult to capture all these nonlinear
complex local relationships so deep
learning comes to rescue right like what
happens is you go logistic regressions
of logistic regressions right so what
what you do is let's focus on local
areas of an image okay this is called a
convolutional neural network this these
have been around for a while as well we
have been using them to classify images
for for quite a while so what it does is
hey okay instead of the entire image
what if I just focused on this area
right this window okay so this guy is
only going to basically represent with a
single number what's going on in here
okay then we slide the window
this guy is focusing on those four
features this guy is focusing on those
four this guy on those four right and
then remember these wired like this
square and that square now I can do the
same sort of sliding window of
convolution by making this guy focus on
these three this guy on these three okay
so basically what we've done is we have
added X additional layers and the very
very final number that we're
representing is again like 0.8 or 0.3
that's the probability of the whole
image being real right and these
functions in here are basically
representing something about the content
of these sliding windows that way by
sliding the windows we can capture those
local intricate sort of like complex
nonlinear relationships right if any of
you have dealt with any like natural
language processing actually the idea of
anger Am's were instead of counting only
the word frequencies but actually also
counting sort of phrases or multiple
words next to each other isn't that far
removed from this idea right
you basically kind of zoom in on local
parts and then bring them all back
together okay so the one thing about
deep learning though is I should tell
the history of deep learning really
isn't like hey we came upon this like
really simple idea and like once it
clicked it worked it's not it's really
not like that there's a lot of debt but
also a ton of mathematical hacks and Oh
like rectified linear units work really
well in this architecture and then well
when we do batch normalization instead
of dropouts like there are all these
mathematical tricks and stuff so part of
the reason I'm saying this is if you're
not super familiar with like deep
learning if you want to get your hands
dirty I would really recommend
I mean maybe like the simple ideas from
scratch implementing them from scratch
might be useful but if you want to play
with these latest sort of like
technologies it's good to take some of
the implementations that already exists
by by people and sort of like go from
there
because all these sort of mathematical
hacks are taken care of in that kind of
like code base okay
here's how it actually looks like this
was our toy example of the letter this
is the discriminator from the 2016 DC
gann paper one thing you'll notice is we
had three by three by one as our initial
metro image this is 64 pixels by 64
pixels on red green blue three
dimensions right so we are basically
making that 5x5 window that's sliding
right because you're sort of sliding
that window you're actually getting
a narrower smaller one so now it's 32 by
32 this these are no longer images this
is basically think of it as like
matrices in different levels and because
in here we don't know what this number
really represents we all we know is that
it's about this part of the image we
don't really understand what this number
is doing but when we train the whole
thing for this to work out it works out
but it is hard to like say if during the
running of this this is spitting out a 5
that's going in there what does that
mean we don't know so again in here you
can see this kind of almost like as a
shortening and elongating of an image
but it's no longer really an image like
thing here anymore okay so basically but
then we keep doing this until at the
very end we have our final basically
logistic regression it's very close to
logistic regression which gives us a
single number take an image single
number okay so this was a discriminator
how it worked okay and what about the
generator they're kind of a little bit
more interesting ones
well actually sort of like what it will
do is take a bunch of numbers and return
a three by three by one matrix right so
actually maybe it's not that surprising
but when you look at it there are some
like minor details but it looks almost
like the opposite of the discriminator
right like there we start it with a bit
of big image and it ended up with a
single number this is a very similar
structure in terms of the matrix sizes
and stuff but we start with hundred
numbers and end up with an image and
these weird things that you see is just
that when you're going to reverse that
convolutional window sliding becomes a
bit more complicated because of like
some geometric algebra thing but but
basically it is the reverse of starting
with hundred numbers
and an alpha they with an image and I
did all of this using tensorflow
like the code is online you can actually
go play with it yourself as well but as
I was saying it's really useful to sort
of take some actual implementations of
like new papers and technologies out
there it really solves a lot of the
headaches all ready for you and I
believe me it can still like create a
bunch of headaches and also there are a
bunch of like when I was working with
these I've actually corrected like a
couple of bugs in there which is like
very normal I'm sure I introduced some
of my own so build on top of other
people's work the reason I wanted to
show this is just this part of the code
I just wanted to show you with
tensorflow like how simple it might look
that entire architecture that I was
showing for the discriminator this is
the code to describe it this is it and
this is the generator like you can see
there is a look it's a little bit more
wordy but like it's really a good
interface where you can take like an
idea like that and actually convert it
into code without much difficulty and I
didn't wrote it that was basically a um
Kim and I also used some of Brandon a
mrs. work okay so I went over like how
these things work right like the arms
race now I can actually generate faces
that the discriminator can't even tell
from real faces that looks great and
basically what we ended up with is a
good image generator right so those
hundred numbers right you can think of
them as basically hundred numbers that
describe the properties of a face and
our generator will take that and turn it
into a face now we have no idea what any
of those hundred numbers really refer to
or have any sense of like hmm I want a
more glass wearing face I should change
these numbers towards this direction
like without actually going deep down
and creating vectors that's
typically do specific transformations
that is hard to do we don't understand
what those hundred numbers are but what
we can do is hey now that technically
any image that it creates is supposed to
look like a face we could just give it
random numbers for those features and
like hey what kind of faces does it come
up with right so let's create a bunch of
numbers give it to them and here are
some faces that it generated for me
again I want to show like something like
this right where this is not a
psychopath
at all I think this person is melting
this is not really a person and here
again like pretty passable and please
don't haunt my nightmares right I don't
think that person has eyes but anyway
the thing is what it has learned is a
lot of these complex and your
relationships like it knows oh hey this
like nosey kind of thing and it knows
that there are like a million different
noses and when I say it knows this
obviously it doesn't have an
understanding or a representation that
we could understand but it has
understood those like local complex
relationships and sometimes it doesn't
work out really well but it's still like
at least has the shape of a face and
remember I could always train this more
with more images too so this isn't like
the ultimate end of the algorithm so
more images some interesting things to
note like you can see glasses somewhere
the images though those two million
images have people with glasses on them
but not as much that not as many as
regular people without glasses so
glasses will care like not so much but
it kind of pulled them off right okay
and more faces like with the coolest
sunglasses this person wins but okay I
didn't even begin to tell you about the
cool part okay so those hundred numbers
that vector representing a face that
happened that that they live in a linear
space what that means is you take those
hundred numbers right take one of them
and very slightly change it
and give it to the generator again the
face it comes up with is going to be
slightly different indeed but it will be
very close to that that first face that
I started with so similar vectors give
you similar faces but even better is you
can actually do algebra with faces right
these are linear vectors that you can
add and subtract from right you can go
to this point which represents this
image and hey jump to that point by
adding this vector or subtracting that
vector you can do math with you know
let's take a smiling woman let's remove
the neutral woman at a neutral man we
have a smiling man right like you can
play with glasses what's happening is
again we don't have like these two
numbers tell me what the glasses are or
like how the glasses should look like
it's not like that but we can actually
construct these subtraction and
additions to basically figure out like
what's missing like what's in here but
not in these for example right okay this
is fun doing math with faces all right
but let's get back on track because as I
mentioned before this is all about my
vanity so now that we have a generator
okay like what number is what a picture
of my face take I'm kind of curious
about that right so if I could actually
take a face and go the opposite way and
sort of like figure out what numbers
that face actually is represented by
then I can do math with like any face
that I want etcetera so great let's get
started here's our dilemma this is what
the generator does it takes those
hundred numbers gives me an image
doesn't work the other way around we
didn't train it to do anything like the
other way around so basically what you
have to do is all right which input will
generate this like one really stupid way
of doing this is that obviously hey
let's keep generating random vectors
until we hit my face right not very
efficient obviously but
for searching large spaces we have like
a lot of optimization algorithms rightly
so all I have to do is what if I started
from a random face and then just push
the numbers a little bit in the
direction where it would make it look a
little bit more like my face right and
keep doing that and keep doing that
until I get the numbers so what I'm
doing is basically giving you a giving
you a bunch of numbers you give me a
face I'm comparing the pixel values of
of that face with my image and then I'm
calculating a score of like how well of
a match it is and then I'm trying to get
to a better match by nudging those
numbers right okay one thing to note
also this works better if you don't only
just try to make the exact same picture
by focusing on pixel differences you
know how the discriminator is also sort
of like having an idea about how real
the face is like it will say this is 80%
a real face I'm almost sure right like
that
80% I'm also trying to maximize that so
that it looks like a real face and not
like one of those nightmarish creatures
okay because you know like a manatee
okay now here's me telling the computer
to generate faces that look exactly like
these pictures of my face horrible
lighting all like cropped out of
Facebook or something they're different
there are some black and white some with
glasses I'm curious how it will do
alright here we go
boom all right now I'm kidding remember
how I said we will start with like
completely random faces yes this is not
what it came up with the mimic this so
this is each of this a completely random
100 number vector so basically a random
face it's just more random faces but now
I'm going to start nudging each of them
to the corresponding one right like so
this is how they change as I changed a
hundred numbers
see they're turning into me except that
guy and here's one interesting thing -
so do you see this I have glasses and
here I don't have glasses and I'm trying
to look like Clint Eastwood or something
like doing this squiggly thing but this
is interesting this is telling us well
it couldn't rip like replicate the
glasses here probably because it hasn't
seen enough similar glasses in context
to figure out like how to do that or
something but what it does is remarkable
it actually sort of alright gets rid of
the glasses and it still looks like my
face without the glasses which is really
really interesting and you can also see
that like these are not perfect right
first of all hundred numbers instead of
all those like 64 by 64 pixels is much
smaller so we are actually compressing
things but more than that basically with
like the amount of training etc that
we've given it it doesn't it cannot
create any type of face image right it's
sort of like limited in what it can do
and this is why they're like these some
of these differences in here okay now
since it worked with my face and also to
be honest like this the faces that I
trained it on were celebrity faces this
is a free to access academic data set
out there on the internet that you can
play with too so these are all actual
Matt Damon faces these are all random
faces that again I just randomly
generated we're going to nudge all of
these entities are you ready for the
Matt Damon a'f occation of these faces
yeah let's do it
that's working yes
again some of them are like pretty close
I think these are okay and some of them
are like not so well but you get the
idea
finally we can't like if they're going
Matt Damon we can't not do this with
George Clooney Haider so here are
Clooney's here want to be Clooney's okay
so by this point I have a bunch of
numbers for a bunch of my pictures for a
bunch of Matt Damon's pictures and bunch
of George Clooney Speicher's remember
the whole idea is to prove that my face
isn't that different from this beautiful
face by the way I chose someone without
facial hair mostly to show you like how
that changes and like how how that
affects things and remember for either
of these faces I now have a set of
numbers that I know if I give it to the
generator the generator will create
something that looks a lot like that all
right so I know the numbers for this guy
now the numbers for this guy what if I
actually went from here and slowly like
in a hundred steps or something like
that slowly go from this vector to that
vector and actually showed every single
interpolated image in between right that
way well the one right here the one
close to here will be really close to
this place the one here will be equal to
the close to my face but this should be
a smooth transition what's more it
should be that like anything in between
should be able to pass as a face too so
it's not like hey just like fade out
from this fade into that but everything
in between needs to be a face okay
computer turn my face slowly and gently
into Matt Damon's are we all ready this
is what we've been welding for so let's
go
okay first I turn into a demon and
that's Matt Damon I know right that's
what I said okay so each of those images
that you're seeing corresponds to a
different vector in between those
vectors okay and this was like my goal
all along like look how similar we are
right but one thing I was also curious
about was okay so all those different
images obviously like my face doesn't
have a hundred number vector associated
with it an image of my face has right
like obviously the lighting the colors
everything framing everything has to do
with something like my face doesn't have
those numbers this has a separate set of
numbers this is a separate set of
numbers so okay this is a linear space
so in this space of vectors that
represent these faces this lives here
that lives here that lives here so like
what if I found two points right in the
middle the average vector that should be
like the essence of my face right like
this is kind of like what is the
stereotypical ear mark face shared along
all those different sort of images okay
so this is my essence a shady goatee
keep in mind also this isn't that many
images I have a feeling like it would
actually get clearer if I could use more
than just something like ten images for
me but this is the Platonic Matt Damon
the averaged out Matt Damon and this is
the eigen Clooney
so one thing you'll notice is that these
two movie stars essences look a lot like
each others and very different from this
guy so this is the point where I was
starting to get sad and stop tinkling
but the gans
but I just want to share before we
finish I just want to share like a
couple of moments that like blew my mind
right after I've sort of like played
around with these and obviously we have
to play this out this is the most
important slide okay
so here's what did this to me now we
actually did like they actually did this
stacked against on top of each other
there are actually two stages the first
stage kind of generates a rough draft
almost like think of like a painter
doing a sketch first and then putting in
the details and not only that actually
this whole thing is now coming with text
descriptions so basically they showed it
a whole bunch of bird pictures and said
this year is a blue bird with a white
wing and a small brown tail or something
like that right and here's the image so
basically once you train it like that
you can instead of just say hey give me
a random bird image by you know like
generating hundred numbers and turning
it into an image instead you can say
remember those coupling with the
descriptions hey generate images of a
small bird with a white breast light
gray head black wings and tail and this
is what it imagines these are all again
not real birds completely generated and
hallucinate it by a computer given this
prompt right and it's mostly correct
right like so the white breast light
gray had black wings yep I find that
fascinating
one other thing by the way a lot of work
like this is coming from National
Geographic or something like you can see
the background is blurry that's because
of those like lenses that they're using
like really really shallow
focus of depth and it has also learned
to make backgrounds like that because
that's what it's seeing right so
remember it is not necessarily learning
what a bird looks like it is learning
what a National Geographic image of a
bird looks like kind of - so keep that
in mind and I just wanted to show you
this thing the first stage second stage
thing like it starts with this and then
in the second stage it turns into that
right rough shapes and then details it's
really cool and finally so at the
beginning I talked a little bit about
augmenting intelligence and what that
means in terms of creative endeavors
right like right now people are working
with ganz for example in different areas
such as hey let's generate a bunch of
assets for video games real cheap or
something like that right there are not
directly ganz but related technologies
like deep fakes where they put a famous
person's head onto like a porn scene or
something like that so there are like a
variety of ways this is being used but
the thing that excites me the most is
things like can we create tools for
creators where okay you want to let's
say make a scene and quickly try
different emotions like it's like what
would this look like if this person is
smiling or not or like you start with
like a sentence and you can make it
shorter or longer or in this case
hey the different versions and molecule
could could shape itself and then what
the properties of that could be so a lot
of a lot of ways to take away really
really difficult tasks from people's
minds and then turn to putting it into a
slider so that they can focus on
creating with those things instead of
focusing on tasks that are not directly
related to that creative endeavor and
this is going all the way back to
removing the brick
from that pencil right and finally I
have the image of the most ridiculous
Star Trek of all Star Trek 6 in this
they go back to the 20th century and
Scotty here is talking to a mouse saying
like this is how you make transparent
aluminum and then they like make some
transparent aluminum and I save some
whales but what this is reminding me is
that we're slowly getting there right
like all the minutia of like figuring
out what the molecular gram should look
like etc that's somebody computer in
this crazy out there like science
fiction campy craziness but we are
getting there right you can just like do
the sliding and we are pretty close to
living in the future thank you very much
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
English question sure the question was
with images for example we have to keep
making little adjustments until we find
the right image like we have to adjust
the vector to find the right image what
this means it is it needs to be
something continuous where you could
make small adjustments and the result
changes slowly so that you can calculate
gradients or how things will change in
different directions and basically do
what we do here so going back to Rome
and Sloane the question was about well
you can't really have gradients with
sentences so how does that work and
indeed you basically need a continuous
space so with images like you can have a
tiny tiny amount of difference between
one image and the other one basically
one pixel could be slightly darker but
with words for example it is difficult
to go from one word to the other you're
making a jump basically what Robin
Sloane is using there and also this has
been used with like work Tyvek type of
things is that you can still assume a
continuous space and discrete things
like words live in that continuous space
and you can kind of play around in that
continuous space what this means is that
you make a little gradual difference and
the output is exactly the same word or
the same sentence so we don't have those
gradual differences but not unlike
starting with the word King for example
and representing it as a vector and then
subtracting Queen
sorry subtracting man and adding like
women gives you a queen something like
that you can do mass with these vectors
what happens with sentences or words
though is basically you have to do
subtraction and addition like you have
to figure out the vectors and then add
and subtract them and what where you end
up is basically in the vicinity of a
word or a sentence and then you find the
closest word or a sentence so there is
still like things we can do in those
discrete spaces not as easy as sort of
like training again on faces yeah good
question so an idea what we really focus
on is human needs right so in a project
for example almost the first half of the
project would be talking to people also
exploring like expert or data analysis
that kind of stuff but and usually we
use deep learning very very rarely
because it like really right now there
are some very very specialized specific
sort of problems which it can it can
work really really well in and we can
use something like that in terms of like
you know as a intermediate process but
we did something around fashion for
example where we took all the images of
of a certain year of like fashion
designs and we first use deep learning
basically already trained models for
image classification to represent them
in terms of like features that are
meaningful and then we basically mapped
out all those images so that like
similar images are next to each other
and you can kind of see on a given year
like which area is crowded what type of
like styles are used a lot as well as oh
there's like a gap in here so maybe
there's an opportunity to create and in
fact not that we did that but you could
do something like hey this is a map with
like a lot of the polka dot dress stuff
here and you know like these sort of
like summer dresses here and whoo there
is a bit of a gap in between you could
click here into that gap and it could
use Gans to actually generate something
that would go in that part of the map
for you right so this is one example of
like how we use how we might use these
kind of things but honestly when I was
working with this like I said was this
completely vanity I wanted to sort of
get familiar with the technology it was
just a fun way of playing with it
obviously it gives you like an idea of
like how it works and then the next time
you're doing your an ideation session in
front of a whiteboard like with post-it
notes trying to come up with like how to
do something it just pops up and then
you can do it
so yeah long story short we don't use
these things that much yet but hopefully
more soon yes they get you know record
an actual person's voice then they're
able to transfer that person's voice to
someone else speaking confusing similar
technology yes and now I can actually
watch the presentation everything but
they can talk on the phone and actually
sound like the exact first like Donald
Trump that's technology today yes what
about video conferencing where now I can
sit in for the computer who's not only
do they see me or hear me speaking as I
would from but now see me how the
computers me I am Donald Trump to them
they yes me an see me yes yes
computers powerful enough to hear the
letter do we still need to process all
this instant because a lot of this is
showing it's just stationary picture
yes video yeah so that kind of stuff
which is like where they're transferring
one type of movement from one source to
the another yet they have they have been
working on this it is like now working
really really well and very very soon
you could just do it like on your
computer too like in fact I bet it's
going to be like on they're going to be
filters on snapchat and like the long
Trump like filter I don't know if that's
going to happen but I but you know those
like zoom or Google Hangouts you can
like click something and it gives you
like a little funny hat or something
like that so basically it's just an
extra like that is getting way better is
basically what's happening but I also
wanted to mention another thing there's
also a lot of worry around it right like
so you can fake you know this complete
other person but today I feel like
Photoshop has been around for a while
and you know like this has been
Photoshop is like a part of our you know
language now we understand it I I know
this is shop because of the pixels is
like something else but you know so we
have biases around it we have different
mechanisms around it when somebody's
like voice today like when tapes get
released for example people still say
this is manipulated because it is
possible to manipulate and edit them
right so it's not like suddenly we have
a whole bunch of new technologies and we
don't know what's real anymore I feel
like this is just an extension of this
type of mimicry that has been in our
lives already we just have to adjust and
get used to it
when you're talking about you showed the
average of all of your faces like yeah
sure think of it like so if you actually
do this in pixel space like you take all
of my images and average them that still
looks like an average face and it
actually sort of looks a bit unlike you
like things get more symmetrical and I
you suddenly stop recognizing yourself
and stuff but with that if you average
like more images in pixel space things
get clearer
mostly because if you just take the
pixel averages of like two things like
two images it's going to look like
ghosty because things like one nose will
be here the other one will be right next
to it and you'll be able to see it but
if you superimpose like a thousand
images right like it will be kind of
like quick sketching where you go over
the same line a hundred times and now it
looks right even though maybe none of
the individual lines look like right so
I'm still talking about just averaging
all the pixels of my faces I'm not
talking about vectors or anything like
that but just because these are
different images with like it is not
only capturing what makes my face my
face it is also capturing am I looking
that way is it like black and white like
is the light hitting me here so if you
had more of those the parts of that
hundred-number vector that deal with
that kind of would get rid of itself
through noise hopefully and then the
things that are more about my face would
be left because those exists on every
single vector but the little noisy
things that can make things blurry are
not the same on every single one so the
more vectors you have the better it is
it's not that it has learned my face or
anything like you said it is not
learning my face I'm just saying if you
average more things you know that the
noise cancellation will make the thing
sharp
we time for one more question yes and so
the question was why yawns and not
something like variational auto-encoders
like or other generative things and it's
true guns are not the only sort of
they're not even the only deep learning
based image generation framework I
wanted to play with Ganz mostly when
like they came out like in 2016 they
were like everywhere and then people
have been working on them and improving
them with different sort of lost
functions and stuff I just wanted to
really get familiar with it I was
already kind of familiar with what
autoencoders can do and for others look
if you don't know auto-encoders are very
similar but a single network that is
again wanting to create images it starts
with an image right let's take my image
we start with it turn it into hundred
numbers and then blow it back up to
itself so it's kind of like hey if I
compress you into these 100 numbers and
now blow you back up which compression
scheme will give me the best
reproduction at the end right so I'm
trying to basically figure out how to
represent this image in hundred numbers
so that I can create it from
representation again so it's another
method and then you just train it you do
it with again millions of images and it
learns how to represent that what's even
better it actually does go both ways you
could give it an image and get numbers
or you could give it numbers and get an
image so but they don't they don't look
as convincing as gams in some cases
obviously this is a subjective remark
but people have been coming up like I
said with interesting loss function
formulations which do tend to correlate
with how we also think of its of an
images quality and gans have been doing
better so new technology wanted to learn
it and
there interestingly different than other
images great so I've definitely learned
a lot today
and I hope you did it as well so let's
give Eric another round of applause
thank you